you talked about the feminization of men
for a second was that you were you i
think we both we were probably talking
about the feminism
i brought that up you're but you're
nodding because i mean natalia do you
have a lot of experience with feminine
men um i see more a lot of them today if
that's your question like metro type men
yeah you see a little bit more men more
in tune with their emotions a little bit
more open to
i guess visually even seeing men
being more feminine
yeah so if 10 men approach you you're
very approachable by the way pretty
attractive and attractive attitude which
is the number one thing about natalia um
shout out
um if 10 men approach you how many would
you say that's a man's man how would you
say he's like complete beta and then how
many would you say he's kind of a metro
he's like a fluid more of a guy i don't
want anyone to come for me but i would
say maybe like
to
six men out of the ten would be really
manly oh really yeah i would say so
that's counter counterintuitive what
we're learning about here you're saying
that 70 are more manly um those are the
ones approaching it those are the ones
the pipes those are the ones that are
approaching approaching me
now so you're saying the more uh
feminine men are probably too scared to
approach a pretty good yes they're a
little bit more scared and um
yeah they're just a little like i feel
like today men with like big egos are
the ones who are like you know ready to
approach women usually like i would say
like
nice guys good guys they're more on that
feminine side because they don't want to
be like overstep their boundaries
in a way um but i think we talked about
this or i watched something the other
day um women like to have like a man
approach them women like a manly man
like women don't like oh like he's shy
he doesn't want to come talk to me like
girls don't like that they want a man so
i feel like
you know men have taken a step back from
doing that so the femininity has gone up
um but
yeah i just that's just my team well
thank you for sharing natalia so um i
know you talk about this the
feminization of men quite a bit i'd like
to open this up for discussion but let
me just read this article the
feminization of men cheats women out of
our natural desire to admire strong men
we've talked about this before
surveys have shown how women today are
drowning in a sea of unhappiness despite
the progress they've achieved in
attaining equality with men right
could that be perhaps the reason behind
this wave of unhappiness in so many
women's lives are uh that arose from the
diminishing power of maxwell and
strength what are your thoughts well
clearly um the uh hell and we've been
talking about this for for ages i think
that what the the most interesting part
of this is whenever you see articles
like this it's this plea for men to
become more masculine to solve women's
problems it's not about men like
benefiting themselves like here
build yourself up and be a better dude
build yourself up be a better dude
because women won't need you to be a
better dude that's what it's not okay
they could they could care less about
the state or the condition of the guy
they just care about the guys be more
manly we need women most affected right
that's that's the whole thing it's
self-improved stop being so selfish
natalia is nothing so damn so you see
him he's just being mad for himself no
you see a man you're like i want that's
a guy i got into this i guess
with jedidiah is like we're at a point
right now where it's like women are
wondering like where where are the real
men at where they're how come they're
not approaching me i'm most women
hello
mostly what they what they tell me is
like they would love for uh like today
the number one way that men and women
meet is online they made on tinder they
made a hint
that's simply they don't meet in church
they don't mean friends they don't meet
at school they don't meet at work they
meet online and those are the ones who
come out more feminine and believe it or
not they're the ones who are a little
bit more like oh you know a little more
shy because they won't approach you in
person but over the phone they have all
this bold stuff to say that was true you
probably have the stats on this that was
trending in that direction they're in
covid obviously that's that's that's
well accelerated right through the roof
and again what i keep saying is like the
old order way of thinking about dating
we don't date in happy days anymore we
don't date in like you know the sock hop
and we're going to he'll have a malt
after the dance box days
we're going to go stare we're going to
go steady yeah we love the idea it's
romanticized but that's not how we meet
today and it's again we're 21 years in
the 21st century but the other thing i
was going to say is
i hate this kind of [ __ ] right here
because it is telling men to man up
after generations of telling men to man
down
so when we say well where are the real
men at how come they're not around that
you want to know why we're having the
conversation about should a man cheat or
should a man not cheat or a high value
man should have a harem a soft harem
however they want to do it it's not
because men are going yeah man this is a
great idea i think i'm going to go do
this it's because women can't get the
strong alpha guy that they all feel that
they're entitled to right now so they
would rather share a high value alpha
guy than be saddled with a faithful beta
right now because they don't want that
boringness they can get the benefits of
you know provisioning protection
parental investment that the beta used
to be able to provide for women but they
do it themselves
how do you fix that
i make my own money
they don't they don't need men but they
want men okay what kind of men do they
want strong masculine guy who's
traditionally you know
conventionally evolutionarily is a
strong dominant alpha male but my
question is so what things have
encouraged men um to become that more
feminine side like bring out that more
feminine sedation first and foremost
like what well pornography is number
that's the easiest one you think
watching porn makes a man more feminine
absolutely because it sedates them they
have no reason there's no incentive to
do anything you want to know why guys
are listless and rudderless primarily
it's because we have uh industrialized
our forms of sedation whether that's
porn whether that's video games whether
that's
legalizing marijuana where that whatever
keeps you in bed and not getting out of
bed to actually go do something like i
can be
again we can be the most influential
teachers on the internet we can say get
out there and go do this and
smash in the gates of hell right you
leave the church or you leave the
youtube or you leave whatever and you
know what you're right back where you
were it's a it's an extra version that
is actually an introversion and once you
get to that point if you're still if
you're still uh you know locked into
pornography and i think it's like 68 of
christian men admit to being admitted to
being addicted to pornography what that
is sedation not very crisis and that's i
want to know if i have if i have a beef
against like sedation or against uh
pornography that's the thing is if it's
if it becomes so so consuming that you
can't get out of bed in the morning and
all you're going to do is just do barely
the bare minimum to to do what you have
to do to survive that's not living and
that's not prospering and that's not
becoming any any better than you are and
then there's also you know uh we can
talk about the opioid epidemic too which
no one wants to talk we'll probably talk
about it around election time but that's
a that's a huge sedation right now uh we
legalize marijuana that's a huge
sedation uh and people are going to come
at me and go oh i smoke weed i'm still
no you're not not as much as you would
be if you didn't smell that's true
alcoholism name the name the sedate food
what would your advice be or
you know stop sedating yourself yeah
well how would you
reverse that well let me just before you
answer this let me just
what you're saying actually makes
complete sense because a man used to
have to get out of the house and hunt
yes
i mean i'm talking just historically and
then even and before the internet age
now
pop a pill smoke some pot order some
doordash jerk off on your phone why do i
even need to get out of bed anymore
mm-hmm you want to know why
yeah well the other thing is like when
we talk about the 80 20 rule and let me
clarify this 100 of women want to get
with the top 20 percent of guys the 80
that they don't want to get that they
say are unattractive those are the guys
we're talking about right now those guys
who are like oh i don't have a chance
i'm no i'm you know nihilistic hopeless
blackfield doomer you know what was me
um that that 80 percentile right there
is always been there and it's always
going to be there so is it the
feminization of men or is it like just a
demasculinization i think that i think
uh the 20th century ease with which we
can uh indulge in our pleasures whether
that's food whether that's booze
whatever your sedation you know your of
choice happens to be whatever that is
that is what is preventing i would say
most people from actually benefiting and
becoming uh maximizing their potential
and is it only gonna get worse in the
metaverse
absolutely definitely yeah don't plug
yourself in yeah the the uh i want to
turn it over to you ruslan but the um
you were an athlete you get out of the
house
you know you work on yourself you go to
church you're not sitting home and
playing video games you've been very
vocal about that yeah what's your
prescription
i mean
that was a lot of prescriptions there
man i mean that's as close as that well
when people ask me when people say what
do you what what do you think about like
what because i get this all the time
people will say what advice would you
give to your 18 year old son it's like
you're not asking me for that
my 18 year old self would tell me to go
[ __ ] off okay
get out of here because you [ __ ] i
know this okay what they're asking me is
what do you what would you tell to the
younger generation so what i'm what i
see what do i see my analysis is this is
that everybody all there more guys we
just talked about the lost boys
generation more men in this generation
particularly the last half of the
millennials and maybe all of generation
z
are are the first generations that have
been raised on social media the first
generations that have had the you know
you were talking about yet playstation
was a big deal in the 90s well imagine
you're we were born and you're 2000
you're 22 years old right now and you've
never known a world without a cell phone
without the internet without social
media without being able to do this by
the way this is the only time in history
we could actually do this um but we take
it for granted i mean i come from a
generation that's prior to all this so i
kind of can sort of get the balance of
this but you have to remember that the
the the generations that have been
acculturated and socialized in that
environment they have no frame of
reference of anything that was before
that so it seems natural to them like
i'm going to smoke weed i'm going to be
sedated and i'm going to do that me
looking at this from sort of this god's
eye third person view i go okay stop
sedating yourself or it doesn't matter
what i say or what tools i give you get
out it's pragmatic advice if it's advice
here's the here's what you need to do
get out of bed stop sedating yourself
get up and go
yeah i think you get everything he said
i think could be defined in a simple
phrase and i tell my son this all the
time if you do it is easy your life will
be hard if you do it is hard your life
will be easy so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
[Music]